you mentioned that when you see
commentary on underneath blog posts that
a lot of times will come in with a grain
of truth that I'll kind of just shut
everybody down so when it relates back
to your filmmaking is that the same
thing is that where there's a grain of
truth between those actors and therefore
you don't need this fancy set yeah maybe
time I mean if I'm understanding where
you're going with that correctly
depending on what your definition of art
is my favorite definition of art is by
the sculptor his last name is Newman
Arnold Newman I believe he and it's like
this neon sculptor ESS says the true
artist reveals mystic truths to the
world I think that's the best definition
I've ever heard you could reveal a
mystic truth of you know I don't know a
still photo you know mystic revealing
mystic truth again going back to the
execution to the talent it doesn't it
doesn't have to cost money so so again
as a filmmaker right now what I am
desperately striving toward is how do i
as a filmmaker in a sincere way not
anitha matically based way or
agenda-driven way how do i sincerely
engage in truth how do I engage in
beauty goodness whatever life you know
how do I engage in that in an effective
way in which it's revealed to the right
people that are prepared to be revealed
to in my way and I just I don't think
that necessarily costs money
you